daniel verdes bonsoir soirée c'est tout
le monde là ça alalala
bel album que j'ai jamais fait ouais
j'en suis persuadé vrai ouais c
est un moment où effectivement je venais
un petit peu du pain qu'ea et c'était
important pour mes enfants j'étais dans
un jour lundi peu ce qu'est les choses
comme ça maintenant sujet passé ça et je
faire des belles chansons et ea j'ai
fait ce que je voulais et je continue à
faire ce que je voulais et on verra plus
tard mais pour le moment c'est parfait
quoi le problème avec vous je pense
c'est que à l'époque vous avez un énorme
succès avec taxi girl qui était un
groupe un peu sainte et kraftwerk un
comme ça un peu électro pop quoi alors
alors que vous en faites vous êtes un
vrai rock'n'roll heroes avec ce que ça
comporte de taille adage de vaines
injection d'héroïne oui ouais un peu
comme iggy pop disons et le succès que
vous avez eue c'est avec un groupe un
peu clean c'était un malentendu même et
je les accepte complètement la tendance
je voulais dire ok alors voilà vous
étiez au sommet avec taxi girl et puis
votre rencontre avec l'héroïne s'est
passé un petit peu comme dans un comme
dans un film quoi vous êtes backstage
rose bonbon la fameuse boîte de l'époque
et puis un jour il ya un mec qui arrive
comme ça et qui vous dit
quelqu'un veut quelque chose ouais ouais
moi je moi je suis vraiment
j'ai appris je pensais être timide mais
on a dit récemment que j'étais fabrique
sociale donc ça m'était parce que les
interviews tout ça je pouvais pas
répondre
j'étais complètement bloquer quoi et
puis et puis je me souviens très bien on
m'a mis une aiguille dans le bras
j'étais en train de vomir et déjà je me
suis dit ça y est j'ai trouvé avec j'ai
trouvé ma raison de vivre voilà à quoi
donc il a fallu du temps après pour que
je comprenne que bon il n'y avait pas
que ça et puis et puis quoi mort était
vachement plus fort que ça est bon plein
de choses en plus la première fois c'est
gratuit donc la première phase est
construit est bon et aux fameuses une
lune de miel c'était génial je dirais
c'est évident que personne ne prendrait
de l'héroïne si c'était mauvais mais
comme je dis toujours dessus on en prend
pour être bien apprendre en prend au
palais pour marc être mal bien sûr or
vous saturez 15 ans comme l'histoire way
une quinzaine d'années va
des puits grave quoi 5 grammes par jour
c'est beaucoup comme un goy ce mois 5
même plus où et voilà ouais ouais
c'était beaucoup c'est aider j'entendais
guillaume depardieu qui a fait 6 à
bardos moi j'ai dû faire ça en six mois
quoi enfin j'ai fait vingt verdoso - le
rocher pointe je compte pur c'est vrai
qu'on est mon
concessionnaire pour vous en sortir la
mère m'a vachement et des mois
vous dit en parlant de ça d'ailleurs
quand on a une overdose c'est pas du
tout le white flash dont on parle d'un
agent sambre canal c'est une claque de
pompiers dans la gueule c'est pas si
drôle que ça ouais ouais c'est horrible
c'est horrible alain verdeaux ce
vraiment c'est tout c'est dégueulasse
non rien de bon là dedans c'est ce qui a
détruit taxi girl parce que déjà pierre
wolson bas il en est mort lui il est
mort d'une overdose et puis les autres
lance stéphane ils sont partis à cause
de ça stefana
alv assists a repris des études de
maintenant les astronomes
et laurent ouais bien sûr il est parti
au vietnam pour décrocher mais bon c'est
pas un peu meilleur endroit c'est
peut-être la fin vous vous retrouvez à 2
3 avec karen your way et c'est à mon
avis c'est ce qu'on a fait de mieux
enfin la musique allemand quand il
arrivait juste l'ignorer c'est moi c'est
ce couac c'est vraiment un c'est est ce
qu'il va mieux mais un album énorme
produit avec burnel qui s'appelle
seppuku qui essaient de fukui voilà un
album génial merveille s'il s'en est
sorti alors lui extraordinairement bien
puisque maintenant il fait toutes les
chansons de madonna ouais et produit il
fait les chansons de man là mais ils
lemire est complètement parce qu'il
s'est enfermé dans un studio pendant
cinq ans dix heures par jour il
travaillait je trouve ça génial quoi je
suis très content alors à part votre
mère qu'est ce qui vous a permis de vous
en sortir de la dope moi je n'aurais pas
qu'on puisse arrêter la dope pour
quelqu'un d'autre pour même si c'est la
femme qu'on aime ou quoi que ce soit ce
soit ne visite pas ça c'est des
conneries ça on arrête parce qu'on se
rend compte qu'on moi moi moi mon truc
depuis le début c'est quand même écrire
et je pouvais plus écrire vite ça n'a
plus rien se dit ça m'a sûrement aidé à
écrire des trucs dans un enfant de 6 ans
99% des cas où jeter ce que vous avez
écrit la veille jésus vous a aidé
dieu m'a aidé à le faire mais c'est
parfois
directement agglo peur mais ouais
bouzid le christianisme et le
rock'n'roll sont les dernières forme
d'honnêteté ouah je le pense je le pense
sincèrement alors au départ vous êtes
juif par votre père catholique par votre
mère n'est déjà pas facile
alors pendant la guerre votre grand mère
paternelle
madame rose zoom est morte à auschwitz
il vous la belle a marre greenway mental
je suis arrêté à dachau ensuite l'auteur
et que j'ai de se cacher évidemment en
normandie ouais mon grand père aussi à
la libération bottemer a été poursuivi
pour intelligence avec l'ennemi en fait
elle est tombée amoureuse d'un médecin
de la wehrmacht qui était pas du tout
nazis qui étaient là qui était en france
qui étaient obligés parce que son ca
d'ailleurs il a fini en sibérie parce
qu'ils l'étaient pas ils étaient pas
nazi et voilà elle est tombée amoureuse
alors on peut prendre les tirs auraient
français mais mon cul internationale et
puis elle était vraiment heureuse quoi
alors récemment à la télévision depuis
guy bop dire qu'il aimerait bien
retrouver une femme et faire un enfant
et vous moi aussi après si j'ai bien sûr
bien sûr mais je sais pas si c'est
possible encore parce que voilà j'ai 44
ans j'ai je peux faire peur peut-être
mais bien sûr bien sûr je rêve de ça
ouais ouais je suis ouais bien sûr je
rêve de ça donc tout ça maintenant et
terminé tu es un mec bien
je sais pas je suis pas si c'est un mec
bien j'essaye d'être un média bon on va
voir refaire une interview mec bien
[Musique]
daniel darc est ce que vous allez
régulièrement à l'église j'ai au temple
ouais ouais 18 rue du faubourg du trou
de
3 mars oui est ce que vous faites des
accompagnements de gens malades j'ai
fait pendant pendant presque deux ans
mais j'ai des personnes en fin de vie
est ce que vous êtes inscrits sur les
listes électorales
je devrais dire oui non parce que vous
reboucher les tubes de dentifrice j'ai
toujours fait ça quand j'étais un mec
même dans la pire zhang tao boucher mais
je crois ouais
je ne serai pas de motifs risque
puisque vous regardez le journal de 20
heures sur tf1
non non non pas est-ce que marilyn
manson vous fait peur non j'ai peur pour
lui je pense qu'ils qui n'est en train
sincèrement
je pense qu'ils se trompent complètement
acquis qui joue avec des choses qui
contrôlent pas il se rend pas compte de
ce qu'il fait laurier saint pas non à
wells elle est pas méchante c'est sympa
julien lepers aussi il est sympa on
n'est pas méchante dig'espace n'est pas
méchant non plus il est très bien
finalement les radars ça peut économiser
des villes on s'est pas mal ouais c'est
très bien pour la lessive tu sais pas le
blanc est la couleur je mélange un peu
tout ça mais j'ai pas beaucoup de blancs
n'ont plus honte et un mec bien
maintenant mais c'est quoi un mec bien
j'essaie je te dis j'essaye de jeu c'est
de ne pas faire de mal voilà est-ce que
c'est ça être un mec bien j'essaie de
pas faire mal et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de ligne youtube abonnez vous
mettez un pouce bleus